what the heck why does he need to do
this
i don't get it does he want to destroy
his family
prince harry spilling the beans is the
stuff of nightmares
he risks looking like a traitor to the
royal family
the uk media in attack mode today amid
reports that harry will get a 20 million
advance for his new memoir the prince
who the new york post called
harry plotter said proceeds from the
book will go to charity but right now
it's unclear if the donation
includes harry's huge advance and the
timing
yeah it's not great the memoir which is
not yet titled
is due for release late next year just
after the queen celebrates her 70th year
on the throne we asked royal
correspondent and author katie nicholl
if the royal rift can now
ever be repaired there's a real sense of
disbelief both in prince charles's camp
and in prince william's camp but harry
is writing this book i mean
the idea of a royal rift being healed
well i think that's going to depend
very much on what's in the book a
spokesperson for harry told et he did
have a private conversation with his
family about the book
still he's being called out for
hypocrisy i think everyone has a basic
right to privacy
despite his and megan's calls for
privacy he's shared a lot with oprah on
a podcast
and on an apple tv plus docu-series i've
always wanted to be normal
as opposed to prince harry just being
harry
people are now saying well how can you
expect private life when it splashed all
over the tabloids
at your doing so what can we expect
the publisher describes the book as
intimate and heartfelt
harry said quote i'm writing this not as
the prince i was born
but as the man i have become clearly he
wants to tell
his version of the story he wants to
tell his truth but i do think
underlying all of this is the very
simple matter of making money
well they've made a fortune now more
than enough to retire
for the rest of their lives but a lot of
people are saying at what cost
but i think for harry that is a real
[Music]
problem